happy birthday resident evil to
celebrate 25 years of your undying life
here's 25 reasons to love that you're
alive
barry burton mary burton
yeah you're right but just
take a look at this it's forest
oh my god
hurry this way
that was too close you were almost a
jill
sandwich you're right
technology barry's daughter [ __ ] it
right up the ass
itchy tasty the golden chicken eggs
give me an egg use this conveniently
placed rocket launchers
use this
[Music]
self-destructs gotta go if i were you
i'd get off this island too
she really pushed it
hurry
ah the merchant what are you buying
what are you selling no enough cash
stranger
finally orchestrated tension
jesus christ
finally orchestrated dialogue what is
this
stop it don't open that door
what is it
[Music]
i've sent my right hand to dispose of
you
your right hand comes off this finely
orchestrated
[Music]
musical
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
this not so finely orchestrated
[Music]
music
[Applause]
it's like when your cat walks along your
keyboard it sounds like a cat walking on
a keyboard
ah the safe room music
[Music]
steve burnside because well
someone's gotta love them uh sorry about
that little misunderstanding
but i thought you were another one of
those shut up chris redfield
alone at a playground
leon kennedy's hair and that cozy jacket
of his
actually you know what just leon asked
kennedy no thanks
bro it's cgi movies and this
incredible fight scene
it's american ones
[Music]
using ink ribbons and typewriters to
save your progress
genius
[Music]
herbs as a health system ingenius
mr x's fedora because why not
[Music]
resident evil 4's salamander boss fight
it's like the third act of jaws smashed
into five minutes of mayhem
smile you son of a [ __ ]
the alligator in resident evil 2.
holy [ __ ] why not the sharks in resident
evil one
in fact just big watery monster things
yeah
ada wong that's it just 801.
put your hands where i can see them
sorry
but following a lady's lead just isn't
my style put them
up now
bit of advice try using knives next time
works better for close encounters
the opening of doors
the guy who says resident evil at the
start of
every game
president evil
resident evil 4
resident evil you're ridiculous in every
which way and i just
love you with resident evil village
coming out this year you can best
believe
we'll be covering it every which way we
can so make sure you're subscribed to
this channel to stay up to date on all
that spooky jibber jabber and if you
like this be sure to also check out our
resident evil timeline
explained it's ridiculous you'll love it
links to that and other resident evil
related content in the description
below all right this was curtin divina
you were listening to and here is to our
undying love
for resident evil stay spooky kids see
you later
[Music]
you